all right look let's let's let's end the
week right what do you say mike why
don't we end the week hey
our boy he's got stuff to say
i love this guy it's about time for us
to listen he's the greatest thomas
murphy thomas murphy is the [ __ ] goat
what's going on bud it's me thomas and i
realized yes
the mall in orlando florida is yes
going to be really busy this month and
besides that yes the mall in orlando
florida like around the parking lots
yeah
just to know yes around or orlando
florida at the shopping malls like the
indoor mall yes locking your car door
yes
lock your corridor is not good enough no
more in orlando florida
somebody went to florida mall somebody
went to obt
something happened we know what maul he
might have gotten something happening
obt in americana somewhere in that area
not a great area
not a great area nowadays
it's not good enough because you know
that right it's not good enough
locking your car door not good enough no
because i think that happens in orlando
florida
smash and grab that's what a semester
grab looks like
but just be sure you look like a knock
on the door
no my car doesn't look at it again not
good enough no you're not paying
attention that happens in orlando
florida
smash and grab smash and grab he's so
great
i love it if i had like an
actual news network he would be the
great
um the guy that does all the safety tips
oh of course you're going to thomas
murphy for a holiday safety tips and
stuff
lock your car mm-hmm smash and grab
[Music]
just be sure you have to put your stuff
in the trunk and make sure you
water your christmas tree dry christmas
trees
are a fire hazard yes water them
every day yes and sometimes you should
hug people that do safety tips that's
that doesn't happen yes and that happens
yes
so it doesn't happen again the smashing
grab
i love the way he keeps saying smashing
the smash and grab i've had a couple of
ladies reach out to me that are trying
to hug thomas
by the way so you guys know it's
actually emotion we're figuring it out i
still
i'm standing on my ground you need to
suck
and also yeah my advice to you is yes
unless you want charcoal in your
stocking this year
don't behave badly i don't want that
you know what he is he's santa clause's
enforcer
that's my advice thank you don't behave
badly
that happens sometimes in florida yes
he kind of nailed us there people in
florida do behave badly
yeah you know why do you know what it is
thomas because we're allowed out
oh he just wants his dick he's barbecue
hey oh dunked on thomas murphy what's up
boy congratulations
yeah what's up dude how's that mask
ordinance
[ __ ] he said [ __ ] avenues
and also oh yeah i am glad
yes i will watch macgyver on friday
nice [ __ ] awesome good for good taste
he does
i will and i'm gonna watch homeowners so
i can tape the parts like uh
i'll pause the parts like so you can do
my videos yes like the one the
the one thing you should never do yes
what and um well i guess it's about it
so
i guess we're going so i gotta go so bye
bye bye bye that was a very chipper bite
yeah
yeah for him he's got a taste somebody
goes tape yeah
jim edward's like he's got to tape him
alone he does remember he wants to get a
demon still wants to get a donald trump
tattoo on his leg so
thomas murphy he's what we need to bring
this country together